l'ancienne prison militaire de la rue de
la mitterie à nantes un bâtiment
désaffecté devenu le refuge de 34
familles de harkis des familles dont les
jeunes enfants n'auront pas tenu à leur
première année le souvenir du brillant
soleil d'afrique du nord bien au
contraire comme lé loi la lumière de la
méditerranée comme il doit sembler dur
le climat breton à ces gens qui ont
quitté leur patrie et qui n'ont pas
encore trouvé chez nous un vrai foyer
pourtant qu'il faut vivre et dans une
chambre sommairement meublées
la soeur aînée apprend à lire en
compagnie d'une cadette sous la
direction d'une étudiante bénévoles bien
sûr ne doit-on pas admirer ces jeunes
qui vivent dans des conditions plus que
difficiles et dont la soif d'apprendre
n'a d'égal que celle dévolue aux
conditions difficiles
est il besoin de le dire et de préciser
sur ces images ces anciennes cellules
sont devenues des chambres mais si
désormais la clef est à l'intérieur
le jour notre pas davantage pourtant la
liberté pour être réelle n'at-elle pas
besoin de lumière
on rit quelquefois à 7 dans certaines
chambres 160 personnes habitent là soit
60 personnes dont 72 enfants qui
connaissent la salubrité quotidienne une
maladie chez eux et c'est l'épidémie
il existe un comité des dollars qui nous
savons que nous ne parlons jamais en
vain des misères à soulager alors vous
avez vu ce soir n'oubliez pas et soyez
généreux